tomorrow
it's going down bigger it's going down
tomorrow
if you don't have plans you do now
if you guys miss this live stream you're
an idiot listen you're an idiot
i flogged myself punished myself no no
we're getting covered right before that
is going to be even better don't make us
look sad because you are so depressed
now oh here's what happened we had all
of these plans and part of these plans
were highly sexual activities and i
really
by the way i'm bringing the butt tape so
it's going down please bring out the
butt tape and also this i need every i'm
gonna do um um an enema prep before the
show because i need you so far up my ass
i'm going now esther's already there i'm
gonna go remove esther from upside down
you guys april 13th this is tomorrow
tomorrow
you only have a couple hours left to
purchase tickets you will not regret
this any and all juicy
um
things about us that you want to know
secrets answers just a fun time where
it's happening in real time and it there
is nothing like it baby and i just feel
like our energies are aligned maybe [ __ ]
is going to go down and i have a
surprise for you guys that i am
so excited about i can't this could be
the end of our show but we're willing to
take the risk also if you think you're
the only one with a surprise plan don't
watch the [ __ ] out did carlos surprise a
plan for us
momenthouse.com trash tuesday is where
you'll get your tickets we'll see you at
momenthouse.com trash tuesday get your
tickets right now it's gonna be chaos
it's gonna be so good we'll get to the
bottom whether copen's real or not see
you guys
this weekend you can see me with one of
my best friends in the whole world josh
potter in san francisco at cobb's comedy
club that's gonna be april 15th and 16th
then i'm gonna be here in los angeles at
burbank and flappers comedy club june
18th for one one night i'll be in new
york in april syracuse i'm going to be
in san jose california may 6th through
7th
uh dania beach florida may 12-14 omaha
nebraska
may 20th through 21st west niagara new
york june austin texas august i'm going
to be in pennsylvania and pittsburgh i
have a million other dates i can't even
get through all the tempe arizona
kansas city missouri a bunch of places
just go to annie letterman dot com shows
i'm coming to you baby listen up
dc
brooklyn
minneapolis chicago those are all coming
up very soon get tickets now esther on
ice.com and
you guys it's so fun it's an experience
it's we are so excited to meet all of
our sluggies it's like unbelievable have
a special night with us and we'll see
you guys enjoy this episode
[Music]
um esther you came in with wet hair but
that was such a cool girl move when i
was growing up in the philippines really
because it meant you had like indoor
plumbing oh i love this bra i like this
bruise
like that someone just [ __ ] gripped
your ass up and was that carlos get in
the car
were you trying to take a second bite of
a cupcake carlos came and beat you yeah
we have eating disorders [ __ ] no we
don't well yeah
here's my thing if we
learn your triggers baby girl that's on
you okay
you look at us because we do our own
thing and whatever we want that we don't
just do what you want us to do that's
why you like us
so i learned to control your triggers
and i'll eat one half of a [ __ ] bite
of a cupcake if i [ __ ] watch it were
people pissed about um oh yes they were
so everyone was so mad at how we can
learn your own triggers learn how to
manage yourself they're like it's your
birthday you can't eat the cupcake i'm
like it's my birthday i'm going to do
whatever i feel like i don't want to get
a [ __ ] also i just
sh like inhaled like a whole pound of
hash browns before i got there that i
had eaten breakfast i had already done
yoga it's so disgusting actually it's
actually disgusting that our fans would
ever dare put that on us you would dare
put on your own feelings about your own
body and your own eating on us
we you know how we lead by example we do
whatever the [ __ ] we want whenever the
[ __ ] we want and that's why you watch us
i
we i haven't
seen my dreams all day if i want it's
none of your [ __ ] business
hi dr drew oh do you have any celery
juice for us good timing come on in
celery oh celery juice yes celery juice
celery it's like veggie tails but with
jewish hi
hi how's it going looking very fit
huh he's coming he's looking very fit
thank you i did i forgot that i was
gonna be on camera and i just threw on
it it's hot outside it is so hot outside
no we're always on camera we don't want
to waste our youth
oh geez
so so what's up what's happening here
where do we start we want you to tell us
what's wrong with us i mean i can tell
you i feel offended that you think you
need a doctor i can tell you [ __ ] go
ahead let's hear it okay esther has
control
esther has um
esther uh idolizes wealth
wait that's literally you
no no i am wealthy
and you idolize me i don't idolize well
i just enjoy being rich but um
i have a subconscious belief that i
deserve money now but it took me a sec
that's beautiful lived in my car um yeah
you've you're changing you're an edible
girl now so i don't know
but i have to catch up to you guys
we're so happy you're here guys let's
introduce the guest properly yeah um
when i was a
very sad immigrant coming to the united
states at the age of 15 i was very i
didn't have any guidance about my body
sex there was nothing out there
our this week's guest
was my north star you taught me
everything i i would have been
so dead on the side of the road a big
bag of bones if it wasn't for you so
very kind now if everybody was here what
would you say to him the opposite no no
but he was part of the reason it was all
digestible right it did work perfectly
yeah yeah anything you know we're under
attack now we're for being creepy and
for you know not being sensitive to
issues that everyone's so sensitive to
now you're in the right show
i know the thing is
what's motivated me to do in the first
place was speaking of north stars
anthony fauci pounding on us young
physicians to get out there and educate
about aids
and that was really my original
motivation one of my original
motivations to doing it and he was all
he was a big important person to me
during aids i took care of probably
thousands of aids patients
i know you were an aids guy this is cute
i did lots of that lots of pounding out
the aids i liked it it was it was hard
man
now i'm saying look there was there's
nobody around to tell the the tale of
how dark that was how awful well i
remember in elementary school we read
like ryan white's story and stuff it was
like it was top news but this was
hundreds of thousands of really talented
young men just destroyed and this thing
would just tear people apart it was a oh
it was a terrible illness 100 fatality
not a 1 fatality 100 fatality different
thing than than this last pandemic yeah
you don't know it was 100 fatality you
look shocked i didn't he came in hard
with aids i like that he came in before
azt which got us over towards the
antivirals and before we came up with
effective treatments for 10 years it had
a 100 fatality rate wow that's and it
was fast back then and i was a third
year medical student it could be i was
routinely telling people they had six
months to live
we were never wrong either they come in
with their first episode of pneumocystis
and that was the trigger that you had
six months wow clock is gone we don't
know what's going to take you it's going
to be a lymphoma or a cmv or
coccidiomycosis in the brain or whatever
um
you know it was so but it wasn't a and
it wasn't like you have six months to
live so go enjoy your life it was like
you're about to get really sick too yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah esther we love to open with aids on
this show we do well i was gonna say i
loved you on celebrity rehab because i
knew that i was gonna be the one you
liked the most i loved i loved mary
carey on that show and i thought like it
was really cool mary is doing really
really well really yeah
she she's uh had a couple more
treatments and really got into sobriety
yeah really good how many of the
celebrities after shooting are like
please cut me out and are just begging
or are they interested like do they feel
like so vulnerable it's so vulnerable to
people
having been on the show yeah like like
afterwards like right so i'll tell you
some interesting stories uh when we
first did it i was very nervous it was
not my idea somebody came to me and i
was like you can't do that and we sort
of kept thinking about it and solving
problems and all of a sudden we were
doing it and um
and i was like you know i just don't
need to be sure these cameras aren't
harming you guys you're okay so every
you know the groups you would do every
day i'd start the group and i go you're
all right okay it's okay you still want
to do this you should feel good about it
and i was doing that for about two weeks
and finally mary carrie leans into me
and she goes uh drew i've done just
about everything in front of a camera i
understand what this is no big deal to
me i thought oh good for her if people
don't know she's an adult she was an
adult entertainment yeah she still does
a lot of stuff online she's benjamin
button she's now young she's uh sorry
okay so so
what
unknowing to me there was a wonderful
transition that happened every single
patient most of the people came on the
show to [ __ ] with me it's like mess us
up to get paid to be on tv
and a small percentage also knew we were
knew us because we treated them before
or something and they wanted to get some
treatment for free and to get paid for
it you know they were getting paid um
all of them went through this transition
where they came in
you know
being problematic and trying to screw
with us us taking the treatment very
very seriously them recognizing that
participating in that getting something
out of it and feeling good about it and
every single person by the end of
treatment was like oh my god you're
really doing something important here i
want to be a good example for other
people i got to make sure i really take
this seriously it was uncanny every
single one of them went through that
transition did you do it i'm so grateful
for that i didn't know that was going to
happen but it did for everybody so that
was good and a lot of them we had to
treat them long after right the three
weeks of treatment is not you're not
done that's what i was going to ask so
there is a continuation of treatment oh
yeah i made them put aside lots of money
for ongoing care for people if they
needed from you or no i well i did so
you're like the cameras are i did it for
free because i felt like it was my
obligation to fill these guys out but uh
we would just put them in halfway houses
and psychiatrists see them we had lots
and some of them refused it someone
refused but we gave it to them they
needed it did you ever think any of them
were kind of like faking having an
addiction
some there was there's a few things that
happened that that weren't on camera
thank god that were like confusing to me
some people
i have a d i have a i still i think i
have a i can't talk about it yeah place
where where people
didn't belong there so we didn't put
them on tv that's awesome esther maybe
we can get you high enough to go on
celebrity rehab
you have to have addiction you don't
have to be high after no she actually is
like
one of the f very few examples i've seen
of like weed really being medicine and
working we're she yeah she's my
daughter's canvas was her drug of choice
and she's in recovery now really
you have to be careful okay what do you
mean thank you for saying that because i
think that's exactly what happened to my
partner bobby lee yeah you know you know
i sat there and told him there was a
problem
but that was before anybody knew
including him yeah and i was like dude
something's not right you remember that
conversation yes i do and he's avoided
me ever since yes and i'm i'm like what
the hell dude he's doing so much better
sure he is but he's avoiding me for some
reason
i'm going to see him in austin by the
way oh you will i'm going to go to the
cheeto santino oh good good good yeah
and i and i
don't tell him i'm going to bum rush him
but i need to ask
how do you know if it's like a problem
consequences if you're having
consequences okay yeah and and and
there's sort of two there's three sort
of hints a family history of alcoholism
if you have that background okay i have
that um oh come on b is you've you'd
like to stop you try you can't stay
stopped she's never tried no comments
but yeah he had never tried and then
three is consequences and by
consequences worker school finance
health legal what about this birth
okay that was from a massage
relationships relationships is often
well they're massaging a blunder
relationship yeah if your relationships
are [ __ ] up because but that's nice
yeah right but that's the thing it's
like everyone anytime there's a
conversation about um you know weed it's
always like oh but it's just weed it's
just weed and that was perpetuated and
bobby said it is just he would justify
it i'm like look at the consequence
there's literally he's a consequence
it is just it is just weed in the same
sense that it's just alcohol yeah right
because if you have the genetics for
these disorders
nothing's just whatever whether it's
alcohol or weed or
benzodiazepines whatever you have to be
super super careful because you have
this genetics um if it's the average
person who likes to drink glasses of
wine and smoke some indica at bedtime
fine
fine i can't even imagine drinking two
glasses of wine what the hell would that
be that's how my fiance is he literally
can just have like a little bit of wine
and he can have a moderation
34. yeah so so the fact that so the fact
that that
looks odd to you
you know what i mean i would just go i
was going hmm
but esther there would be consequences
if you stopped taking animals
and i'm not advising you to do anything
no i don't know i think everybody's got
to do what's right for them that's all
yeah well and i keep telling people
people think i'm like the the party
pooper or whatever i'm the
way my thing is like if you have trouble
stopping and you can't stop and you want
help
i can help yeah that's it that's it
i'm also i've never tried alcohol and
weed i just discovered it like six
months ago have you ever tried alcohol
no because of your parents because my
grandma grandma yeah my parents don't
drink either but um well
yeah it's a weird situation and i'm
we're figuring out day to day but do you
feel sorry is there is like a problem
where you're like i [ __ ] up well one
of the things here's one of the trick
one of the clues i'm not saying it's a
categorical clue but one of the clues
that there could be a problem
is
usually when people are first exposed to
cannabis they're like ah no big deal and
then like around as though there's some
priming effect of this drug like the
second or third or fourth time all of a
sudden it's like whoa this stuff is
awesome and the thought that comes into
your head is i love this stuff i'm like
better on this i love no i love it i
love it do you love it
why
because because that's the thought that
people have when they have this biology
it's a it's a it that you could be
heading for trouble what if it was i
loved it on the first try though it
happens that way too oh okay you must
about do you have a lot like an edible
or something i'm gonna um yeah i have a
question about i'll take it up to get
that right i'm just i'm gonna
tell her
you are everyone around you is happy too
it's like you are it's i've and i um i
used to so it's working personally this
is i used to be on record
because for me it's like has a it has a
bad day right you're not gonna be an
addict ever what's that you're you're
never gonna be a weed addict it feels
shitty when you take it well i no i
think it's never gonna it still feels
shitty and then i take it and then i
take it and stuff i have a problem with
weed i don't
it's hard to have a problem if you feel
shitty on it well i i feel not enough
but i like the being bad
that's different so i used to smoke a
lot
back to that statement
do you remember wait do you remember
when i did like a very quick sit down
with you on your radio show what you did
the it was the comedy store had like an
event at the fonda
theater yes yesterday okay i was there
too i bombed so hard i did i bombed so
[ __ ] hard and then they're like go
let's talk to dr drew so i sit down i'm
like i'm my face is i'm spinning like i
bought so bad we were outside like we
were getting heckled by helicopters like
planes were going by i was like in hell
and then brody had just [ __ ] crushed
yeah and then he was like i gotta get
off this earth once he talked to you
i'm just kidding oh my god i'm joking
okay i talked to him more recently
if we're gonna blame anyone i talked to
him literally the day before so oh
that's a very sad story but um no it's
really just your juice like there's too
much going on no i'm following now okay
it took me a while to get it don't say i
ate [ __ ] and then i saw someone crushing
so then i couldn't blame like the
audience or the circumstances i was like
in my like you were fine you were fine i
was in my shame and i sit down and you
and you said something along the lines
of like so what like you know i this i'm
not quoting you but it's something like
what [ __ ] you up to get here and i was
like you want me to tell my rape story
and you were like oh
oh that's what we need to do
and then i was like uh i just told it on
mark maron's podcast and you're like are
you promoting another podcast in my
podcast and i went yes i am
i just couldn't i was like i can't bear
to tell it again
but um
annie and i were um diddled a lot
molested in every home
just about
uh um as children as tweens as teens and
young adults every stage of our drinking
we have a lot of similarities like we
have excessive like we have
hyperhidrosis
um there are certain
yeah like a lot of parallels between us
like physical management
the
body yes yes
um i haven't read it i've heard people
have given me like readings i've seen
the cover
i have fomo right now
no it's okay i'm jealous of that bruise
um mine was in high school was my high
school teacher but i took him to court
good good for you yeah i got his ass but
it was really i really feel like i the
lesson that i'm learning now is like it
was good that i did that because it was
very the reaction was not positive when
i went to court i'm just telling you you
saved other people i know that's how i
feel too i mean he didn't he got like
three years probation but then when i
told it on mark maren's podcast again i
was very scared i'd still have ptsd
around it yeah yeah i was really scared
to tell the story
and i didn't want to get like sued or
anything like i just didn't know so i
didn't say any names but people figured
out who he was and then i got dms from
people and they're like he was about to
start working with at-risk kids again oh
so i [ __ ] got his ass again what is
that about people that work with at-risk
kids because i was in um i won't say the
hospital but it was somewhere in
torrance and i was there on um i had
attempted suicide as a teenager and i
was put there for three weeks and sure
enough
i got into a relationship with one of
the counselors
yeah that's so horrible but it's like
it's that
you always hear that with like people
who like seek out to work with people i
think it's because we're less credible
like they can be like oh you're like
or maybe our parents maybe the teacher
part of it but on the on the treatment
side yeah it's usually people that are
injured right themselves uh haven't
spent enough time in proper treatment or
not being properly supervised i mean
i've had it happen in drug units where
they go out and do drugs or they have
sex with patients it happens a lot
and that's just
gone for good i'm only laughing at you
white knuckling the chair yeah it's a
lie
even for you we thought you might be
so drew one more hard-hitting question i
was fisted by my family doctor
i think i was fingered on the way i came
out breached and i think the doctor
fingered me out um so when i first came
from the philippines we're dumping
really all our bad stuff undocumented i
know we've been waiting for this day
okay it's all good it's all good um i'm
a little short of breath
esther shorts
the opposite of annie where like i
didn't know um the protocol of how to
report someone as a team and he was our
family doctor in fact he was our doctor
until my dad passed away you know he was
the attending it was everything and so
like we would go in for let's say oh
like i because i was a swimmer i have a
shoulder injury
and somehow i always had a finger up my
ass that appointment you know and in my
head i was like oh this is just how
american doctors do it this is the way
there was a lot of training
in my era
to
always do a recto vaginal they they'd
call it this procedure that we were what
we didn't really
we didn't do it we were like weren't
following the attendings directions so
you do you do a pelvic exam right you
feel the uterus that's what we're doing
for the shoulder injury i'm just saying
this is the procedure i don't know why
he was you know the fact that he did a
pelvic attack
but um and then you're supposed to do
this
so you feel the the
septum between the vagina and the like
but then he would do this and he would
pull out my discharge and say things
like oh you're a healthy girl
and then yeah they call it spin bart
kite this is this is a wow this is a
generation of physicians i'm glad that
you're saying this too because i went to
a gynecologist who wasn't he was an
older he was like maybe in his 60s yeah
this was like and he just stuck his
finger at my [ __ ] and i was like i've
never heard him
so those are the guys that were training
my generation they were like just you
have to do this every time you're not
completing the pelvic exam really yeah
yeah so i stopped doing that long time
ago
but i did it i drank a warning i just
was like i think you're in the wrong
hole sir i've been in this situation
and they're checking for a tool for
blood and other things they feel like
that was a responsibility well part of
it was gynecology from like
60s 70s and 80s was
misogynistic like severely misogynistic
it was all men that was the first thing
i noticed when i went to the my first
gynecology training i was like well
these guys hate women yeah really yeah
before women infiltrated the the
profession
but even then some of the women were
sort of tough on the page like that was
really odd it was very odd the way they
treated patients
yeah
so i um it's gone now it's not like that
it's not like that
um while i think that might have been
part of how he learned to do like just
like that he did it every time you came
in it's crazy yeah and so but i never
reported him but then you know my sister
and i during the pandemic we she was
having a lot of like problems dealing
with with being like touched in that way
oh she was affected too by him yeah and
so was my mom
um and so
um but we didn't know any better we were
just like this is how doctors in america
do it that was the thing but we we
looked him up and sure enough like he
had lost his license i guess like he
would grope women while during a stress
test like he would just
like do these weird things so like but i
always have that guilt of what you don't
have guilt about which is you saved a
lot of people i was so silent yeah i
didn't know what to do when i got called
a liar i had a lot of trauma around that
so
it's really interesting but let's
examine what you're feeling
can we talk about true building i can't
wait to talk about true bill has my
number at this point okay and i did sign
up for an automatic spray tanning thing
and i know annie listen i know you guys
have seen me the past
couple episodes i've been pasty white
you look beautiful but i'm just saying
there has been no sprite tan but i have
paid for it really it's an automatic
payment you know what i've paid for
an app that identifies insects
that's two years i paid 19.99 did i
identify this one can we see what this
one is a little baby spider i'm a
critter
you guys true bill is a new app that
helps you identify and stop paying for
subscriptions you don't need want or
simply forgot about if you were in a
manic episode before you were going to
say hawaii with your two co-hosts and
you thought maybe i want to be spray tan
for the rest of my life so i'll pay for
four a month uh at a certain rate and
then you forget
true bell's got your back okay and maybe
you thought you were gonna be an
entomologist and you wanted to pay for a
service that identifies insects every
insect that you ever see in the outdoors
and
three years down the road you're still
paying for it this is the app for you
apps don't sleep okay you can get a
subscription in the middle of the night
when you are not thinking clearly so
isn't it so messed up that most of these
things like they make it so difficult to
cancel subscriptions oh dude it's they
make it impossible and they do it on
purpose they know what they're doing and
on average people save up to seven
hundred and twenty dollars a year with
troops a week
[Laughter]
because companies make subscriptions
hard to cancel true bill makes it
incredibly simple you just link your
accounts and trouba will cancel your
unwanted subscriptions in one tap and
your true bill concierge is there when
you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to
you guys don't fall for subscription
scams start canceling today at
truebill.com
trash tuesday go right now subscribe to
us and then like it and then go right
now after that go right now that's
truebill.com trash tuesday it could save
you thousands a year
by the way
i know we all this is a product that we
all use and
people may not know this but 30 million
women are impacted by weekend or
thinning hair and if you're among them
no we're balding these boys are taking
all the attention from us you're not
alone exactly
not only that i'm not balding but i've
had this like these baby hairs forever
okay and they pop up and now that i've
been taking neutral it's like they're
getting longer and flatter
look this isn't an overnight fix and
this is why i believe in the product
um if you
take it every day as recommended for a
couple of months you will see a
difference i know i have after i turn 30
my hormones just kind of went wacky on
me and i started shedding shedding
shedding since neutral though i can
finally say
i have my hair back for once i never
thought it was possible i have to say
too that i'm seeing it everywhere now
and i'm seeing more and more people
using it and having results and i feel
like we're part of spreading the love
and i'm proud of us
and who knew that we had to worry about
our hair aging ladies
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
neutraful.com
trash and save 15 off your first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it is only available to us
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order thank you
nutrifoal get 15 off at nutrifold.com
spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com
trash
so
so much of being traumatized
is shame and guilt
right and you're you're taking that
shame and guilt and you're making it
explicit which is i should have saved
people also
don't don't do that yeah you're a kid
you what do you you come on
it's you cannot explain you had a you
had a dude that was doing some very
strange victimizing that you'd have
you'd have tar difficulty identifying as
an adult
as a kid it's like no don't do that
yourself
that's shame from whatever came before
too it's all connected it's all it is
all connected shame is a horrible
emotion it's just the most important
thing is to like
get yourself healthy and stuff too
because i i mean i do really think most
of the trauma was around the coming out
about it was just the reaction to people
yeah yeah of course well you but you you
got explicitly shamed
you know not only i was a [ __ ] crazy
yeah and had you been abused before that
too uh-huh oh my god
so oh we cry and we laugh on on on trash
tuesday
because it was while we were all getting
molested we were we had solace and
listening to you and adam corolla
and how many trauma victims we were
dealing with
and i think i think we went through a
pandemic of trauma from starting the 70s
i blame the 70s i really do it would
literally people would say things like
you know children are just little sexual
beings or whatever whatever you're into
man you do you acted out whatever and
they did the same thing to women too so
the reason you have a harvey weinstein
is because that era was raised on women
want sex as much as you do and you know
how much you want it they're they're
suppressed by society you got to bring
them on be as aggressive as possible to
help them yeah that's the [ __ ] that
was going on in the 70s i'm telling you
that's what was going on
children are sexual beings women need
help by being by being aggressed against
it was the worst decade of the american
experience
my high school was
had started out in the 70s as a a um
montessori school and then it turned
into like an alternative school we
called our teachers by the first name
which if you're calling your teachers by
the first name they're [ __ ] you um
there was just no boundaries in between
yeah i mean it was like boundaries were
blown apart in the 70s and then and then
you know hey whatever you're into was
sort of the cry of the day and kids were
and then kids that were sexually abused
have a certain probability of becoming
perpetrators too
and
she feels left out we have to you know
give her a little story okay okay i hear
you
and then
and then people that perpetrate don't
perpetrate on one person they do it to
many many many so this thing grows fast
well that's the most because it's like
you're not even special you weren't even
act out against you you were left out
no like if no would you like there's
still time
there's still time no no no and i have
my own traumas that i'm not fully uh out
with like they are because they're brave
um
you're not brave
let's do it together i have loads of
trauma in my chest
i had a mother that was nutty yeah
just think not munchausen
that's mommy dead and dearest yeah mommy
dearest mommy dearest john crawford yes
yes yes okay no wire hangers but really
significant emotional abuse yeah
sorry esther
what
let me let me let's go let's go on the
on the success side i've had lots and
lots lots of treatment
and what i've been left with you know
what trauma leaves you with a certain
amount of some assets too right
so one of the reasons i'm good at the
clinician is i'm i had to
tune in to my mom all the time and make
sure she wasn't losing her [ __ ] or
because that would come at me so i got
very good at tuning into other people
and that now that i have boundaries and
that i can regulate my emotions that's a
that's a significant asset yeah i mean i
can feel what's going on without even
looking at you i can feel it but isn't
that um that certainly i'm talking about
yeah so like that's been my um
kind of i feel like it's a curse is that
i've had to be so fine so so acutely
aware of my mom's little switches
because there was an implication for
myself you got to get treatment have you
had treatment i've been in therapy since
i was 14. on and off i have had um brain
spotting let me get you some emdr going
oh my god but see the first time i was
so freaked out after brain spotting that
i didn't because it was during the day
what is brain spotting it's basically
like you have so you have like binaural
beats um in your ear yeah and then based
on where you look
is it it um
it taps into either a memory or a trauma
and um it is so for me it was really
overwhelming i would i didn't have
anyone at home to kind of decompress
with afterwards and it [ __ ] me up i
was so freaked out and scared and like
spooked for three weeks after that that
is more of an anxiety treatment
specifically
um
not speci it works for trauma as you get
into it but it does make you feel [ __ ]
up yeah i mean but my really good emdr
therapist will all say that after after
somebody really first couple sessions
they will it's like purging it right
they will accuse the therapist of having
broken them like you broke me oh i
didn't go see i didn't see the therapist
again she felt like she did something to
it she broke you yeah like i remember
was that on the valley um
no it was well i did it from home that
was the point oh no no no no no no no no
no i remember vomiting yeah yeah i it
was just so yeah jarring it was
delighted herself so excited no i'm just
so happy you're here it's like i really
like i'm like about to cry because it's
just like it's nice to have someone that
like understands what we're talking
about and you well it was like a lot
yeah it was like a lot of the [ __ ] and
we joke about it and it's like funny and
i'm glad but it's nice to have some
stuff
but it's so nice to have you and it is
like it is like a nice like
you have a good energy it's like not it
just doesn't feel we don't feel judged
we don't feel no you shouldn't feel
shame you shouldn't feel good shouldn't
feel judged yeah and you should hold
back yeah i mean this is the this i see
this as the problem of our time i really
do and the more you can joke about the
more you can talk about you've talked
about it with me on podcasts and stuff
before and you've been very open about
it and i think that i i firmly believe
that helps not just yeah you it helps
you to be that way that helps other
people like you there you've done it
you've helped other people you've talked
you've helped right in front of me i've
seen you help other people it's so cool
and like when we go on the road and like
all these people come up and they're
like you know i was blessed so
it just feels so like what we're like on
this earth
it's really good you gotta get you can't
just go but part of it is acknowledging
opening it up yeah sort of i don't want
to say normalizing it but but bringing
it into the room so to speak but you got
to get the body right yeah because the
body is what [ __ ] is [ __ ] up because i
think that tmj and like i feel like our
bodies are in fight or flight with the
like armpits you gotta read the book
how do you know how to treat how do you
know to read yourself
like how do you know what to do to get
better
it's a really good question right and
how do i know what's the right kind of
therapy and that kind of thing it really
depends on the case okay uh and you kind
of have to find your way sometimes like
if you're on five milligrams of lexapro
and you take an edible at night after
you're set
like and nobody you're not hurting
anybody
like is that cool are we cool
you and i are cool you are very cool
yeah you're doing good esther i'm proud
of you
i have a feeling yeah and i don't know
you very well at all but but but
but because we've sort of done you know
i
we've all done other stuff together um
i'm going to bet you know cognitive
behavioral therapy would help you which
is an easier kind or kind of okay cbt
okay okay cool i like i do want to give
you that like a quick recap of what
basically last year i had a miscarriage
and it was a really
traumatic post the dnc like i had it was
in a lot of pain clyde was helping me
through that and i i never have like i
told you i've never tried drugs or
alcohol like i've been sober my whole
life because i had a like an addiction
to food i was a binge eater i did a 30
day treatment program like eight years
ago whatever i'm
in recovery for that but and doing well
um do you talk about your substance use
though in those groups
um i haven't done i don't do i'm not in
groups for that anymore okay um i did oa
but i it wasn't a fit but anyways so i
had the miscarriage
was in crazy pain and the doctor had
prescribed me hydrocodone and
i would normally never touch anything
like that but i was in so much pain i
was like dad give it to me totally
appropriate yeah but then
i really liked how i felt that night and
i called two of my guy friends carlos
and our other friend john and was like i
like a couple weeks later i was like i
actually really like that like i think i
want more of that and they were like
don't do that maybe try weed and that's
how i
[Laughter]
well it's a lesser problem that's for
sure okay
feel like it's a problem or do you feel
like you like have heard it being a
problem with other people and you're
afraid it's gonna be a problem good
question i feel
when i think about that honestly i'm
like
it's not interfering with my life but i
love it so much be careful that i know
that that's the dicey that's disgusting
that's not that's not a normal
relationship with a substance okay i've
had patients tell me
i've had patients with guns in their
mouth
and who tell me they couldn't pull the
trigger because they loved their drugs
so much they couldn't do that to the
drugs oh my god that's how much i got
they're like relationships they're like
love them
and so that's you know that's part of
the addictive process you look they're
playing about that's a plus for drugs
they're used to
life
pros and cons
are plenty of alcoholics that still
drink and do okay yeah i mean they
manage to control it and whatever
they're people that do it if it's just
if you get to a certain point then
that's so weird i i quit drinking when i
was 25 right when i started comedy and i
feel like so lucky because i replaced
that drug with like my career
so i never feel like i'm going to drink
again but i definitely like
i'm not like bobby level like smoke weed
and it can be sober right now he is
sober now he's doing yeah
he's a bobby's a real
serious drug addict i know he's like a
hardcore
he's got he told me the stories i was
like dude yeah i didn't know with his
mom chasing him through the fields with
the car bouncing
down
oh my god it's he's got stories that are
watching it's never just like right now
like and it's very apparent because even
if he's sober from alcohol so we're from
you know the drugs really cutting down
on his quote-unquote process addictions
now we have bags and bags and bags of
sunflower seeds showing off that there's
going to be something it's going to be
always something that's going to be
something good but you see how different
you're a different flavor than bobby
right okay bobby is like oh like he has
got to do something yeah there's no his
life is in jeopardy if he doesn't you're
in this sort of contemplative bad
relationship with a thing that's odd not
right and you're just you know you're
figuring it out okay so i'm i can
i'm not telling you i'm not telling you
anything i'm just saying that you're
you're thinking is good and you're
trying to figure it out okay you will
see dr drew yes ma'am um
fighting forward is that okay yes am i
still not in front of anybody's camera
or anything i think you're good oh
what is um
you because of your relationship with
your mom when you were younger and the
trauma that you endured like what how
did it matter
said that to me that way
how did it manifest in your life either
as a teen and what are some things that
um you kind of um know about yourself
now where you're like oh [ __ ] like that
was very um there were two two big
themes i'd say
uh
one was
uh like in high school when i finally
got a girlfriend i clung like my life
depend upon it like i couldn't deal with
the
breaking up and forming relationships i
couldn't do it i just once once i got
attached i was like oh
i couldn't let go and that poor girl was
the object of that for me
and
yeah it's hard it's really painful it's
really awful well do you think it's
because you like it's because they're
the ones validating your feelings so
then you're like if i don't have them
then like
you know when you have it it's sort of
i know if i can put it in a rational
context but it's not uncommon for
emotionally abused males to get love and
sex addiction
it's just very common
and i just was just you know clinging to
these things in what way were you clingy
like she wanted to break up and i was
like no
what are you talking about i'm confused
seriously yeah what are you talking
about i've also never broken up with
someone i've only ever been dumped
you're still in a relationship with all
these people
so that's codependency love addiction
that kind of stuff that stuff and that's
your alcoholic family okay all those
things esther so you're telling me if
tony hinchcliffe never broke up with you
you would still be with him today that's
a great question i don't like answers
yes
the answer is yes
dave this is in your hands now okay do
you want to marry
but i can tell you it would have to get
very bad before she would leave he he's
gonna tony's got to come see you to deal
with the fact that you don't know who he
is
you've got to send him to a spiral
and it
yeah very quick in the middle of your
sentence and then the other so the other
thing was uh
uh oh when i was dealing with patients
later so i started working at
psychiatric hospital in 1985 and i would
just get cleaned up by drug addicts and
borderlines people who could manipulate
really well with bad boundaries and
stuff because i would go oh you were i
literally would go it's comical now i
was like you're sexually abused as a
child i feel that i could see the pain
in you i see it i'm going to fix it i'm
going to make it better and the drug
addict goes yeah you are you're going to
give me some morphine that's what you're
going to do
so i didn't understand what esther is
doing right now she's like it's cool if
i eat edibles right it's kind of what
she's doing right it is a little bit
it's well i just think she's looking for
some papa to tell her it's okay but
that's my i think i still have a little
bit of that yeah yeah that big desire to
be like let me be your person right let
me help you yeah and so that's an asset
that's a good thing you've got to have
really clear boundaries with that clean
mind because our job
this is respect to the body keeps the
score right is the job is to be present
for that person not to catch their
feelings not to rescue them from their
feelings just to be fully attuned and
available and i got i'm very very very
good at that now and it helps
therapeutically so so i think that's why
i'm like feeling from you so much it's
like so amazing you're pregnant yeah
because you're not like there's no like
leaning in to do anything no no it's
just we're here with it and uh and i
have some suggestions and things but
it's it's in back in the day like i'm
talking 30 40
[ __ ] how long ago was that i was born in
83 so it was 30.
i'm so excited to talk about liquid
death it's actually listen to this guys
that's the sexiest sound that's the
sound of hydration if i ever heard it
if you're that person like me where i'm
like what do i do with my hands
especially in the social setting like
what i do
this is the thing to hold yeah because
you stop giving hand jobs to people next
to you and grab a liquid diet okay
also liquid death is blowing up and we
were totally the first podcast to do ads
for the first people to adopt the liquid
death lifestyle
just have to brag yeah okay and also not
only will it
brutally murder your thirst
it brutally murders plastic
that's right and as trash people
ourselves
we like to recycle and kolyla as someone
who once murdered plastic when you took
the fake tits out right you're someone
who stabs fish for a living also someone
who just lives in water yes i would know
a thing or two about really good water
you guys and liquid death is it this is
the jam you guys can get free shipping
on all water and merch at
liquiddeath.com
trash by the way last night someone at
my meet and greet was wearing a liquid
death sweatshirt and he was like
he was like i just think it's cool oh
we'll get some that's liquiddeth.com
trash or grab some at whole foods
7-eleven albertson safeway or amazon but
you guys support us and show liquid
death that we're the coolest and go to
liquid death.com trash i love magic
spoons so much
i want a bowl of i'm hungry i'm ready to
eat one right now and i heard they have
new honey nut flavor
i need it sorry i just orgasmed i uh i
just honey nutted excuse me
oh it's so good i really haven't had
some like it's been a couple weeks since
i've had it and i am actually craving
why why on earth did we have to give up
cereal the one joy it was just so sugary
it was so bad for us so it really was
just once you become your own mother
you're like i cannot give myself regular
cereal the fact that magic spoon was so
smart to know that we all were wanting
it we were all missing it we just needed
a healthier spin like thank you for
seeing us and making us feel you guys
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein and only four net grams of carbs
in each serving and only 140 calories
it's keto friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy free and low-carb and you
can build your own box and the available
flavors to build your own custom bundle
or cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cookies and cream maple waffle blueberry
cinnamon plus the newly reformulated
honey nut flavor which i need to try i'm
so excited you guys can go to
magicspoon.com tuesday to grab a custom
bundle of cereal and be sure to use our
promo code tuesday at checkout to save
five dollars off your order and magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's backed by 100 happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
you're an idiot but also they'll refund
your money with no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com tuesday and use the code
tuesday to save five dollars off thank
you magic spoon for sponsoring this
episode and for sending me honey nut
it's not always a good idea to retrace
or to kind of
you know you have to understand
generally not a good idea but you can
get to it without like correct right so
to some extent you're trying to for some
people with certain symptoms you're
trying to get to the point where they
can think of an accident say they were
in and not have the bodily base reaction
right so so really what it's about is
not about revivifying experiences or
clarifying memories it's about
regulating your body
and learning to regulate you said right
now you feel it you know that then
that's because there's a part of your
brain that's like
not with us
now strangely one of one of my talents
is i can tune to that part i can and so
i can kind of bring it into the room and
like when i do i like feel really
intense stuff right here with you
is that your spot yeah i have i [ __ ]
blood a lot yeah that's how we bonded
so so that's that's it man and it does
this is not and so the reason i know
it's hers and i get chills from it too
what's that
how to drew you're gonna make me have a
breakdown right now i honestly think
that my biggest barrier in my life is
i'm able to intellectualize everything
that has happened to me because i'm like
these are things that happen to me
but if for some reason there's a
disconnect with my somatic like my body
normal that's what trauma does and so
i'm feeling it right now as i'm sitting
here i know my hands they're so cold
because i'm yeah yeah
dyshydrosis and stuff right right right
right
all right and i as i hate this
whatever just happened just completely
went away so i don't know what you're
doing but you're doing something right i
gazed into annie's eyes she saw she it
was she's my soul no like you're running
away from all this right yeah and and so
but the feeling i just had a minute ago
was nothing i've ever
ever really felt and so i know it's
yours because of that and it was cold
and weird and scrambly and
that good reptilian
he's not wrong touch my hand sister he's
our shaman but how are you
it's this weird thing that you that
humans do we can we can if you open to
the information we communicate in ways
that we just don't all even understand
and and it's all bodily based it's
through the vagus nerve it's called a
socio-emotional with all the biology has
actually been kind of worked out
but it's it's
if you're open and you have good
boundaries and you you see what happened
in the past i would feel the pain from
your injury i'd feel that i got to stop
that now i feel your experience coming
through me and being sort of somehow
being reflected in my body i know how
but i've had when i sit with patients
i'll have hear weird music had strange
smells
pain in certain parts of my body for me
is it a smell
why do i smell potatoes
lilacs
floral
but anyway it's weird but but what it
does is it brings that part of her in to
a safe connection and if i were working
with her i'd i'd stay with that and i go
what is that what is that what's going
on there and she would naturally go more
into that material that's different than
what i'm telling her to do with emdr
this is what i would do with a drug
addict who needs to like very very
quickly we need to get all of you here
and trusting and if that part of you is
not trusting that part of you will pull
you out of the process that part will be
stronger than the rest
she won't be able to control it because
it's there demanding attention and she
doesn't even you can't control that and
then that that shows with people like
looking away stuff like that or it's
just
it's even more uncanny than that right
it's just it's just it's about being
everyone present fully present in the
room
am i fully here
i uh
i think so i'm not sure
maybe listen to the phantom version as
you of you is here here emotions are
high let's have a banana dr drew um um
we have a segment called banana break oh
do i have bananas
dr drew see how you're a man of science
um do you believe in afraid where she's
going
what is this
paranormal like ghost stuff so no i
don't believe in ghosts um and my wife
my wife does very much and we fight
about this no fight we joke about it all
the time she's gonna hug her ass if she
dies first
well they don't believe in it
they will know
i um
you know she she we we were interviewed
by or we interviewed or whatever we sat
with tyler henry you know the psychic
the medium yeah and the medium and and
at the end they go what do you think
what do you what he did i go all i know
is he's not talking to dead people no no
it was my wife goes
how was this she goes well he's great at
talking to dead people i go all i know
is he's not talking to dead people she
was like he's talking to dead people and
i'm like this is back and forth
so i do believe
that much because of these strange
experiences i have sitting with people
tuning to their experiences and
receiving them
i sort of feel like the our
there's something happening there's a
lot of stuff we're not aware of right
our brain is a is it evolved in a
environment of evolutionary adaptedness
with very specific qualities and it it
doesn't perceive anything by any
everything by any means it's a very
it's the most elaborate thing the best
thing in the universe we've ever found
so far but it misses a lot just infrared
light it just it just misses tons of
things we so whatever is happening when
you send information to me and how you
send it how i experience it i i don't i
don't think we really fully understand
what all of that is yet but i think my
suspicion is
that
a lot of the self and consciousness
is a shared experience
and i think we leave somehow parts of
ourselves on each other
and if it's a very do you get what i'm
saying a little little so and i it's a
and if it's a very important
relationship
naturally it's a big imprint on us
there's a lot there in our brain left
over
and i think that psychics tune into that
somehow much the way i was tuning into
your traumatized self they could tune
into
people you feel me trying to break your
boundaries and get it break my balls
don't be scared happy place happy place
um i don't um esther is our she's an
anti-ghost lady she doesn't believe in
any of that and it's interesting to me
mostly women are the ones that believe
in all that stuff too it's fascinating
to me i think you your brain is you know
your brain is better than ours right you
have this big corpus callosum you can
tune into your the right side of your
brain the left side of your body tunes
into bodily based experiences so that's
what i have to call on when i tune to
you but i have to work very hard at it
because well that's because they didn't
stick their finger in their vagina maybe
that's part of it maybe that's the
tuning process
but but that you have really you have a
great instrument for all this so it's
interesting to me that you guys more
more seemingly seemingly more naturally
believe in that emphasis on the
seemingly she's very i don't and i think
my reasoning is like kind of almost
you're not a [ __ ] idiot
absolutely no religion and i think you
kind of need to buy into that to believe
that like there's spirits and stuff
maybe yes
for me i don't have that but i'm
starting to like
try to believe in like spiritual yeah it
seems like it seemed to be nice isn't it
it seems like a good thing yeah yeah
especially because like i grew up in the
same house that my dad grew up in which
it was so is my grandparents house and
they passed away before i was born and
so like i want to like believe that
their energy is there
certainly they're in you okay right
that's what i was gonna say maybe having
that there sort of fills whatever's in
you or triggers whatever is in you in
some way because they're dead we we
leave
the sense of self i think is
far
bigger than the reality of what we do
with and
amongst each other
like for instance i think a collective
something is for sure so i don't know
what it is but it's something as human
humans but that what we do well what we
become and what we feel and everything
we experience is really interpersonal
it's all about other people but is that
just a basic as like
i used to hang out with a friend who
would always tell me that i was stupid
and then like i woke up one day and was
like i believe i'm stupid because i hung
out with this person like is that that's
a little more cognitive but that's an
example of that kind of thing but
wouldn't it be like the tracing back to
like what what is it that happened
before that that would let you hang out
with someone right why would you be like
before you know one of the things no one
ever talks about is attractions why
would you be attracted to somebody like
that yes because there's something in
you like you're searching for someone to
like solidify some some negative thing
that you
have or maybe
something about trauma
and and unpleasant experiences in
childhood sets up attraction
that's sort of why bobby and i always
ask when bobby and i first met 10 years
ago there was always like why do we feel
like old comrades like that's the thing
we're like we should see this
relationship through because we feel
like old like vets who were in war
together but then i'm like now that i
understand it all and i understand his
background i'm like we are old vets like
we have a very similar
traumatic childhood and story and you
know
what we search for and what we're
attracted to our baseline is very
similar as well is that what i've heard
about on tiktok called like a twin flame
relationship where you're like the same
and you connect no that's when your best
friend who's a twin doesn't show up to
your party and you go light her house on
fire
i i don't know what that refers to
really like the twin flame is like it's
like you know
what type stuff people who are dating
and they're like so the same and like so
deeply like trauma and sometimes the
trauma bond is a real thing for sure
yeah yeah for sure if you if you look
why do
the classic is a woman who keeps going
after abandoning men when dad was never
in the picture when she was a kid that's
sort of the classic thing men do the
same stuff yeah but sort of the more
visible one is that one because it
happens a lot i don't have that one i
had a friend that that pointed out to me
that i would go each guy date would
either be like super hyper masculine and
like verbally abusive or like feminine
and very avoidant so it would go like
dad mom and dad well or now my
boyfriend's
securely attached good
therapy yes
um yeah it was self-worth yeah because
some some secure attachment is a hard
thing to come by yeah i can't believe
why i went younger he wasn't taken yet
[Laughter]
younger ladies
but uh
yeah having an alcoholic parent will
make you secretly
yeah
well for me the grant the alcoholics in
my family didn't traumatize me in the i
think like a traditional way because it
wasn't in my like
family unit it was my grandparents and
like extended relatives for me what it
did was we bonded me my mom and dad and
sister bonded over how we don't do that
and how that's bad
so that's why i feel like i don't have
traditional like alcoholic trauma
interesting yeah do you think that's why
you're asking for his approval because
your family unit who you
relate to you guys are sober and then
now you're doing this thing maybe yeah
cause i my parents oh you're letting
down the whole
chain i know my parents do think it's
shady that i'm doing it but they're also
they're gonna start smoking eating weed
soon so they always come for you
eventually i have a question about your
relationships i know that you don't end
them but uh do you start them or is it
someone because i know that
you know like we're dating our parents
kind of so is it like someone that comes
in and takes care of you the way your
mom happens but again but to your point
though you you tend to go all one way or
the opposite that's flip side of the
same coin yeah same thing right yeah but
now that's why down the middle is
good i feel like i'm always the pursuer
like even every guy i've dated i feel
like i've gone after them but
like
non-romantic relationships you're making
me think of something which i wanted to
ask you was like
i have this pattern where i
meet people and i think they're so funny
and so exciting and so intoxicating and
i become almost like obsessed like
obsessed with that person what's that
about she has a tattoo of my name
and she doesn't have one of mine
and that's the big parent
so it it again it's i don't know the
depths of what's going on but but it's
that you idealize right yeah so
idealizing de-idealizing that's what
that is are you also for yourself you're
perfectionist
no but i feel like i hear things about
perfectionism and sometimes i identify
with them but i don't
i'm not aware sloppy my
my mom and my sister were always like
when we did like crafts together like i
always just remember like everything
they did was so perfect and so my
instinct was to be like i'm gonna do bad
and like must be messy but i mean more
in terms of what you demand of yourself
oh yeah hard on myself yeah yeah yeah
that kind of goes together why
just does that sort of notice it but the
idealized because then you kind of you
have an idealized sense of what you need
to be and you know and then you'll have
a idealized union with these idealizes
and if i'm not my idealized self then
i'm so mad at myself and hard on myself
yes and you're doing the same thing with
others which is sort of the common thing
and you get you know sort of all blown
up about those people and maybe you have
some magical thoughts about what they're
going to do to help you be your
idealized self
that feels like an
i don't i i feel confident i don't
really do that anymore but i do know
that sounds familiar for sure like just
yes like us a person is
magical and like almost an addiction
yeah yeah this may sound like a funny
question is it fun
yeah so great
what do you mean it sounds fun it sounds
like you were if you were able to play
with it and not be really destroyed by
it if they don't reflect your needs
perfectly and you can have fun with it
so it's almost just like that's how i
make friends and it's okay
i don't know you will have to say
categorically that's true but it just
occurred to me that it felt like you're
having fun with it yeah and and that's
okay
because maybe you're right too because
in this business it's like i get to meet
new fun people all the time like i was
just on the show doll face and like got
to hang out with cat ending shane
mitchell brenda song and was like this
is so funny yeah so fun have fun with it
i mean it's it's this feeling i get is
you have fun with it it doesn't hurt you
so
yeah if you were like a like even with
your friend christina who's like your
best friend forever she's i'm a twin and
then christina her best friend i haven't
left the house on fire
i have been very close friends with
twins a lot i don't know if that but but
if you were like if you were like
psychotically attached to christina
which i know you joke about but if you
really were you wouldn't have moved away
from her do you know what i mean yeah
you're right that's a good you know you
would have like stayed like right that's
why it's fun yeah do you have were these
identical twins or fraternal twins no
i've just always fraternals girls right
did you lose a twin in utero when you
were no i like to think that she's a
hemorrhage that
we call her our resident teratoma
my god
came across this
tick tock that
kind of made me feel a certain type of
way which was
the girl at a grocery store was asked
hey what's your name like out of nowhere
just somebody coming through and saying
hey like
what's your name and her feeling
immediately like i don't want to give
this random person my name i feel that a
lot oh interesting i and i i want to ask
you it's like why do we have an
obligation to tell somebody who we don't
know our name you do not but let's sort
of examine the interaction so um
people love it
when you use their name that's just a
normal human thing and so when i meet
somebody for the first time i always ask
them their name and i try to use it
because i feel like it's polite but if
somebody felt like you're taking
something if you've had stuff taken away
from you by random people it's just that
you you're you're guarded you don't want
people to take you know your name [ __ ]
you you know you're the first person to
say that i'm guarded because no one
usually because i give so much
information about myself people would
not i'm one of the most guarded people
ever and
most people don't catch on to that i
could see that i could say that but but
i couldn't see how you couldn't be
guarded with that history you'd have to
so my name is just an extension of that
feeling something people taking
something from you and also like if you
think about it it's like the girl's like
grocery shopping it's not like she's in
like an interaction where she's meeting
someone it's like she's just like going
about her day and then someone comes in
and is like give me your information in
the middle you know one of the things i
want to caution this morph the audience
everybody you know when you talk about
traits and characteristics and stuff
i can't think of any trait that's all
bad you know what i mean they all have
adaptive qualities now you may not like
it and they may interfere with
relationships and you may need to change
it but like if you were a fighter pilot
i want the mo i want the most
narcissistic [ __ ]
f-18 that's who i want and so i want in
there i'd like an alcoholic too because
they really get off yeah
yeah and so though that's why one
sitting in the pilot seat yeah um if if
we're in a relationship and you're and
you're guarded that that could become a
problem we're going to kind of work on
that but if you're in a grocery store
you're guarded maybe good it's maybe
okay yeah it's something that like
protected you yeah i was at this
protecting you i was sharing a lane line
the other day with a guy he was like hi
i'm joe and he was asking me about the
long fins that i was wearing
and he was like what's your name
is it worse with men than women it is
yeah definitely with women you know
but he he this is how he said what do
you do
that you're able to do to lap swim at
noon and immediately i was already like
why why do i have to tell you that too
and and i was like oh you know i just do
you know things here and he goes what's
your name and immediately i was like
i just could not it sounds to me like he
recognized you no he didn't though
it's this common thing i i said my name
reluctantly see the interesting things
and then probably you sold yourself and
then i felt i was like i didn't need to
give my name the interesting part to me
is that in spite of you having such a
strong emotional feeling to the contrary
you still went along with it yeah but
that's me to a t i am myself
the more problem part of that whole
interaction was the self betrayal yeah
that's yeah yeah
if i had been there i would have yelled
i would have been like she's not gonna
[ __ ] you dude
i'm like jumping out and just [ __ ]
getting a man away from a girl like this
is what i do yeah i'm super super
co-dependent in that way but i need
another situation where you're like stop
like you can just sense like you're in a
swimsuit he's just trying to [ __ ] it's
like get the [ __ ] away from me you know
you know what i look like in a swim cap
it's not
well that is bringing up something
interesting about i think our dynamic
which is i feel like annie and i in
particular are people who will
we need to be told no
and i feel like you're someone who
you might want to say no but for some
you like you don't like overextend yeah
yeah and it's like tell me more about
that what do you mean you need to be
told no give me an example okay so like
if i'm i
hm
say it i'm like not quite thinking of a
specific but it's more like
i need to be told if i'm annoying you
like i don't want to win you would
rather be told than be doing the act
you're not doing it to annoy someone
yeah so that like hurts it hurts your
feelings if someone doesn't tell you
exactly like i don't ever would rather i
don't want someone to sit and hang out
with me if i'm being just i would be so
much more soothe if you're like i'm i
mean i've had enough of you and i'm like
i would just i wouldn't be offended by
that i'd be like oh great and i could
never say that i i'm someone who was
like i wouldn't dare
hurt her feelings in this moment right
and so that's why you might get mad at
her
but it's
out let's take back the words we don't
mean what we just said so my my clingy
self as a 17 year old or whatever would
have driven you ins you would have been
like it's disgusting you sing it across
the room you would it would have
bothered you why because it's it's the
opposite of what you want somebody to be
oh because i actually uh
wha i'm learning here so i'm i want
someone to say no to me you want
something to be honest yeah you want
somebody to be present you want and you
and you there you know many parts of
yourself that are real that can be
irritating you want to hear when they're
irritating yeah so then why would a
clingy person not because i would never
tell you that i never tell you i'd be
too afraid to rock the boat which is
ultimately me yeah i don't want to i'm
so afraid of um
my parents fighting or my parents you
know like i don't want to
ruin a moment cause a stir
so i just you know
yeah i'm kind of spineless bobby and i
talk about this all the time
oh thank you for saying that i'm not
speaking you're co-dependent different
things and i think that's because i
think if somebody if you really needed
to stand up you would yes i do and i
think that ultimately like pushed to the
corner i'm like all right and you'll
protect other people too vigilantly
yes you'll do it for others yeah i'm
just not talking for herself that's
right not you're right and just not for
myself a lot um i think it's confusing
for you it's interesting i'm like she
can't believe it it's interesting i i to
me it's like we're not
but um i relate strongly to what you're
saying yeah yeah yeah and i'm recovered
from that and i'm telling you it's a lot
better
i'd like to get there eventually i think
that i think iam dara would get you off
the ground really quickly do you think
it's like a black and white thinking too
where it's like if if it's like if we
assert our boundaries it's going to be
like this very negative thing i wasn't
allowed to assert my boundaries as a
child and then if you were to then it's
like it would be this huge thing rather
you know what being kind of like it's
it's that's a really important question
what she's going to do is build an
internal boundary around her emotional
self which doesn't require doing
anything it's just there
you understand right because she could
give her name without it being an issue
feel whole and not intruded upon in
those moments and so she can react right
in a regulated fashion she would go you
girl stay with me she'd go you know
right now i'm busy i'm i'm so sorry it
should be appropriate with him just
saying be able to be fully there right
and i am not i am so disregulated to
where even a tiny interaction like that
throws me off completely and then i'm
spending the next 30 minutes breaking it
down of how i could have done it better
why ultimately it's shame yeah it's the
shame cycle over and over again you got
to regulate all that so the shame goes
away and she's connected to those parts
of herself so that part is there with
her when she's interacting with people
so it really isn't about hey don't do
that that's a different kind of boundary
right this is the micro surgery of
building so that it doesn't even matter
like the the external locus of control
is not as important as like it's
it's the being whole and being regulated
it's funny that i keep pointing in my
stomach for you right
i think i had some of that too is
probably why i'm going here but
i gave myself basically like i have
colitis
so
i bet it goes away when you get properly
treated oh yes it really unless it's
like inflammatory diseases like
ulcerative colitis or like um
i have flare-ups here and there it's not
like a you know chronic thing that i
deal with every day but the higher the
stress
i take um a suppository called
misalignment
yeah yeah can we insert that for you
oh my god yes essentially it'll be an
honor oh my god yes i want you guys to
actually learn how to insert a surprise
toy it's the easiest thing i've ever
loved too yeah absolutely
you're doing a lot of really important
work here it seems like god's work now
it's really getting to the meat of it
you know we're gonna be fingering our
[ __ ] sooner or later aspirants
in a safe place i have to say my mind is
blown still on like the concept of like
you you couldn't net you wouldn't be
like could you ever see yourself telling
me like i'm in love with you
yeah let's kiss like
could you ever see yourself being like
esther like not now or like
um the one thing that i i i've seen her
do that by the way at an airport but it
would come out wrong it would not make
her happy if she did it
correct really so here's the thing
on
during the times where i've been like i
cannot do that or i'm putting my foot
down i still throw myself into a shame
cycle right i don't feel it it will come
off a little aggressive because when she
gets to that point when she has to do
that it'll feel like she'll just be kind
of angry because you've been like
waiting to because it was like maybe
like there felt like a natural time to
do it before that she ignored she
doesn't feel it shouldn't feel it before
right yeah she feels that she's anxious
and then all of a sudden it really for
me is it it is a lose-lose i'm so
disregulated in that way so
it's either i betray myself or i betray
myself
you know what i mean like those are my
two options because i am unhealed it's a
really powerful statement but i get it
wow
i find it so fascinating this is all
uh bewildering territory for you really
that's like a cute part about esther
things are like bewildering a lot i'm
like
what do i so what would someone like me
do who wants to have a relationship with
kalila and wants to
like travel with them and like exactly
what you did which is you told me i like
being told when i'm being annoying and i
receive that exactly as you said it
which is i'm going to try to do that
from here on out it's going to take some
effort on my end but still confusing
tell her more often and more frequently
exactly that
you guys are brilliant with the use of
humor use lots of humor and practice it
yeah but also like esther is like
triggering to some people on vacation
not i swear to god it's not me but like
eric griffin was talking to me about how
annoyed he was that you stayed in the
hotel she's like a potato she's a potato
vacationer she likes to sit and she was
watching the news
it is annoying you're like okay that's
annoying i'm just very used to 12 years
of friendship but
so esther so then when we talked to you
about it you what you said something to
me about because i am just at peace with
that i just didn't expect anything
different from that uh and i think it's
hilarious
it was a school shooter day too she was
literally in hawaii watching the school
shootings it was not a school it was a
school shooter day carlos it wasn't it
was a school shooter day i will say it
was a school shooter day
disappointing so that was not what i was
focusing on i was on my phone but you
but but you said that you would have
liked someone like a producer to come
and like drag you out and force you to
do the activities if that if it was for
work right shooting stuff yes like that
is i would have liked that so you want
someone to is that mom or dad like not
come to it my dad always even still to
this day like threatens like he'll grab
me by my ankles and pull me out of bed
if i won't get up to go i can target
with my mom i can take that role but
you know esther when i see you being
that way and you're a little bit defiant
in some situations i really respect and
envy that about yeah because i
don't have that same defiance i couldn't
stand up to my parents i had to just say
yes to everything that they demanded out
of me i was a racehorse like i had no
autonomy i had no like identity who i
was was what they told me i was so then
i get jealous of that because i'm like
you are a hard worker and you know how
to do things and like i you can
if someone says do this you can do it
right away and get it done like that's
what i hear so isn't that back to that
point of none of these things are all
liabilities they come with assets
everything comes with assets and
liability everything yeah everything but
is it true like because i feel like any
fight i've gotten in with esther has
always been me mad at your boundaries
and then when i think about it i go like
it's actually very impressive like you
really like if you have a boundary it's
like there's no
i'm like but what if this is easier for
me like no [ __ ] and i'm like you know
and then my pattern is to like you know
hold in and try to people please and
then i get so pissed but when i think
about it it's like i do really like what
kaleido is saying it's like i do really
like admire that in you it's like wild
i've like never seen just because we
don't have it literally and it is i do
feel like there is a similarity because
i i have a specific memory of a time
where i remember i texted you if you
wanted to go walk and you got mad and i
was like
why is she mad at me i just invited her
or something but then i like looked back
at it and i was like you
felt like you because i asked you that
you had to yeah because i think what was
going through my head was like
you would go can you come at this and it
would be like an impossible time for me
to get there and then i'd be like now
i'm rushing and you'll be like why
aren't you here yet i'm like because it
takes me longer to get rid of them and
it's at your house and i'm coming all
the way to you but it's like in my head
i'm like
but i wouldn't have been dared invited
you to my house do you know what i mean
like people pleasing wise i wouldn't
have even invited you to my house
because i would have been like she's
going to say no or whatever i mean i
have dreams where you like
leave me
like places like you're in my life
you are tired wait i have dreams like
that not about you but i know they're
not about me
i know esther no my childhood best
friend like where i'm always like trying
to hang out with her and she's off yeah
back to school or yeah but someone's
like is it a dream or or is it the
comedy store and you've left when i'm on
stage and i get off stage to take a
picture with you and hang out with you
do you
[Applause]
do any of these issues
get in or how does how do these things
operate in your intimate relationships
great question i feel like i
accidentally fell
for a guy who's very healthy
how dare you
you went through some [ __ ] together
like literally just got accidentally
lucky that the guy i thought was
attractive happened to be like really
insecure and so
i feel like i've almost grown and
changed
through being with him for so long
but certainly not without its like i we
joke he's always like i should have
broken up with you
years ago because i would like ult i was
like the queen of ultimatums the
ultimatum
but we're like better now and he's
really happy that i'm on lexapro
because i have really bad ideas and
cannabis
yeah uh he's like thinks i'm overdoing
it with that the anxiety can get worse
over time with the cannabis be careful
that's exactly what happened to me i
called 9-1-1 on myself and i used to be
just an avid smoker
and eventually it started to have the
reverse effect i started comparing
everyone and what did you do in response
to that when it first started happening
i don't remember smoke more oh yeah and
then i started really loading up on the
other side i used to say that weed makes
me doubt my leo so then i go into those
shapes you know every time i was big
like if i went on a podcast or something
and i'm in a in a
time period where i'm smoking a lot of
weed i would come over like why did i
say that oh my god i was too much i was
too this or that too big yeah i was too
big on a [ __ ] podcast which is like
the only way to bomb a podcast is to not
talk
um
but really like yeah and then where'd
you guys grow up i'm philadelphia
philadelphia one brother skokie a suburb
of chicago highest number of holocaust
survivors in the country
winner survivor is that your family too
uh
well we don't really know i was
raised quaker lightly raised quaker
what's your ethnicity i'm just curious
i'm sorry like
like 20 ashkenazi from part of the the
holodomor i don't really know
it's just through uh 23andme i've
completely blocked out the war so i hope
it's not ukrainian yeah i i just i'm
going to be a granny they're coming for
me
annie imagine
if you were actually ukrainian i just
wake up every morning and i go i'm going
to choose myself
yeah people speak russian to me
constantly but i'm not but i'm not
russian they don't say you have russian
descent your family doesn't say that no
everyone was it my mom was adopted
which is a lot of
stuff happening from that yeah and then
um
and then my dad's mother was adopted so
the 23 and me said that were
um like twenty percent ashkenazi and
then the rest is like british i think
because of ashkenazi was a was a exodus
from ukraine but people speak russian to
me a lot like in
distressed situations
people always tell me that my because
i'm half ashkenazi and i'm half finnish
and i'm always told that the ashkenazi
the jew side is the jew
i'm russian i must be russian because my
last name is povitskiy and it ends in a
yeah eastern come on keep rushing let's
finish it up sorry and usually when they
say russian ashkenazi they mean belarus
ukraine okay
yeah which is probably what yeah maybe
we're cousins
prop we must be you around my mom maybe
you are related to my mom and you were
raised philippines philippines yeah yeah
yeah and why'd they come over
um
so my sister and i were part of the
philippine national team
for swimming and um
it's very limited the
the support and the resources to become
uh
you trained here right so my dad was
like also my dad had lost all his money
all of his money back home so he was
like [ __ ] we gotta go
and also we gotta you really gotta step
it up and be the price goats because oh
boy um we don't have money for college
so you better get into d1 school
and we did and we're going to take you
to a doctor that fingers your ass and
we're yeah
on top of that we're going to get you
rectally uh raised and we're going to
make sure that you know you have three
suicide attempts before the age of 18.
that's why i ended up in bhc i ended up
you know like i'm very familiar with uh
she down alhambra alhambra twice in
alhambra alhambra and then um one in
torrance where that counselor that's a
good hospital i'm sorry that happened
i don't know about the adolescent
program but you know yeah i mean it was
i mean overall i thought it was a good
stay i remember singing casey and jojo a
lot there and like
he was singing it back
he wasn't supposed to sing the other
[ __ ] part
he wasn't supposed to be jojo
i really do feel like my
like reason for being alive is to like
to like talk about trauma in a funny way
and like help people get over it i
really like love to do that it's where i
feel really most aligned and i talk
about it my set and i like i pound
people that were like molested we have
like a fun moment i do this whole set
and then a comic i'm not gonna say his
name comes up after me and goes wow how
many people did you [ __ ] in that set and
called me a [ __ ] on stage i was like i
had just gone up after chris rock had
done an hour of comedy i like smashed
doing this stuff had this like exchange
of energy with people and he said that
and i was so upset and i like said
something to him afterwards but it's
like i know that like i can't like teach
someone this right teach i can't teach
this man that he can't like i told him i
don't like that he did that did he
respond yeah but he's been talking [ __ ]
on me and stuff about it and it's like
it just was like to me it was like so
hurtful that that's like what he got out
of my set when it's like there was like
this underlying message but that says
more about him exactly yeah i've noticed
uh jen kirkman lately railing on male
comedians yeah and it's like i there's
something going on i don't know quite
that that your story is very vivid and
yeah not okay yeah and it's just i guess
to me it was like but what i'm trying to
sort of
reframe is i think it triggered
something in me where i was like am i
coming off like a [ __ ] or like is that
what i'm sounding like and what i
realized is i'm like i could literally
like heal people through jizz jokes
that's a gift
i mean like i can tell somebody little
jokes
do you know what i mean like i can like
get these messages across while telling
these jokes and so i'm kind of like
reclaiming that and not so but i was so
like [ __ ] i'm trying to that is that
story is shocking it makes me so mad and
then he bumped me the next night and
like like i was punished for telling him
dr drew after an hour of sitting with us
are you experiencing compassion fatigue
yes
i know we came here yes i am and i was
like you know where i felt that right
here yeah i noticed it i noticed it i
normally don't and i thought that was
interesting no no no it's something that
some people do to me and i was trying to
figure out which one he was doing
i'm sorry
i don't think it was you i'm not sure
because it was odd i felt like oh i need
a coffee and i thought you know what it
does
and i wondered is that just me didn't
sleep enough last night no i think i did
no you came in and we were like all
pushing each other
and esther's like i don't have trauma
and then she's like but i don't have a
miss schedule like you have trauma
but but i learned from esther though to
say yes i did feel some drama fatigue
no no everything's fine
yes we need esther to give us more
esther well on that negative note we'll
you guys are great and i enjoyed it like
it turned out to be my i mean it you
exceeded all my expectations
you too it was so funny i know
and we'll see how it goes you give me an
update this is what i'm trying to
motivate yes
[Music]
you